The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN GUTTAG: All right,
welcome to the 60002,
or if you were in 600,
the second half of 600.
I'm John Guttag.
Let me start with a few
administrative things.
What's the workload?
There are problem sets.
They'll all be
programming problems
much in the style of 60001.
And the goal-- really twofold.
60001 problem sets
were mostly about you
learning to be a programmer.
A lot of that carries over.
No one learns to be a
programmer in half a semester.
So a lot of it is to
improve your skills,
but also there's a
lot more, I would say,
conceptual, algorithmic
material in 60002,
and the problem
sets are designed
to help cement that
as well as just
to give you
programming experience.
Finger exercises, small things.
If they're taking you more
than 15 minutes, let us know.
They really shouldn't,
and they're generally
designed to help you learn
a single concept, usually
a programming concept.
Reading assignments
in the textbooks,
I've already posted the
first reading assignment,
and essentially they should
provide you a very different
take on the same
material we're covering
in lectures and recitations.
We've tried to choose
different examples for lectures
and from the textbooks
for the most part,
so you get to see things in
two slightly different ways.
There'll be a final exam
based upon all of the above.
All right,
prerequisites-- experience
writing object-oriented
programs in Python, preferably
Python 3.5.
Familiarity with concepts
of computational complexity.
You'll see even in
today's lecture,
we'll be assuming that.
Familiarity with some
simple algorithms.
If you took 60001 or you
took the 60001 advanced
standing exam, you'll be fine.
Odds are you'll be
fine anyway, but that's
the safest way to do it.
So the programming
assignments are
going to be a bit
easier, at least that's
what students have
reported in the past,
because they'll be more focused
on the problem to be solved
than on the actual programming.
The lecture content,
more abstract.
The lectures will be--
and maybe I'm speaking
euphemistically--
a bit faster paced.
So hang on to your seats.
And the course is really
less about programming
and more about dipping your toe
into the exotic world of data
science.
We do want you to hone
your programming skills.
There'll be a few
additional bits of Python.
Today, for example, we'll
talk about lambda abstraction.
Inevitably, some comments
about software engineering,
how to structure your code,
more emphasis in using packages.
Hopefully it will go
a little bit smoother
than in the last
problem set in 60001.
And finally, it's the old
joke about programming
that somebody walks up to a
taxi driver in New York City
and says, "I'm lost.
How do I get to Carnegie Hall?"
The taxi driver
turns to the person
and says, "practice,
practice, practice."
And that's really the only
way to learn to program
is practice, practice, practice.
The main topic of the
course is what I think
of as computational models.
How do we use
computation to understand
the world in which we live?
What is a model?
To me I think of it as
an experimental device
that can help us to either
understand something that
has happened, to sort of build
a model that explains phenomena
we see every day,
or a model that
will allow us to predict
the future, something
that hasn't happened.
So you can think of, for
example, a climate change
model.
We can build models that sort
of explain how the climate has
changed over the
millennia, and then we
can build probably a
slightly different model
that might predict what it
will be like in the future.
So essentially
what's happening is
science is moving out of the
wet lab and into the computer.
Increasingly, I'm sure
you all see this--
those of you who
are science majors--
an increasing reliance on
computation rather than
traditional experimentation.
As we'll talk about,
traditional experimentation
is and will remain
important, but now it
has to really be
supplemented by computation.
We'll talk about three
kinds of models--
optimization models, statistical
models, and simulation models.
So let's talk first about
optimization models.
An optimization model
is a very simple thing.
We start with an objective
function that's either
to be maximized or minimized.
So for, example, if I'm going
from New York to Boston,
I might want to find a
route by car or plane
or train that minimizes
the total travel time.
So my objective
function would be
the number of minutes spent in
transit getting from a to b.
We then often have to layer on
top of that objective function
a set of constraints, sometimes
empty, that we have to obey.
So maybe the fastest way to
get from New York to Boston
is to take a plane, but I
only have $100 to spend.
So that option is off the table.
So I have the constraints
there on the amount
of money I can spend.
Or maybe I have to be
in Boston before 5:00 PM
and while the bus would
get me there for $15,
it won't get me
there before 5:00.
And so maybe what I'm
left with is driving,
something like that.
So objective function,
something you're either
minimizing or maximizing,
and a set of constraints
that eliminate some solutions.
And as we'll see, there's
an asymmetry here.
We handle these two
things differently.
We use these things
all the time.
I commute to work using Waze,
which essentially is solving--
not very well, I believe--
an optimization problem
to minimize my time
from home to here.
When you travel, maybe you log
into various advisory programs
that try and optimize
things for you.
They're all over the place.
Today you really can't avoid
using optimization algorithm
as you get through life.
Pretty abstract.
Let's talk about a specific
optimization problem
called the knapsack problem.
The first time I talked
about the knapsack problem
I neglected to show a
picture of a knapsack,
and I was 10 minutes
into it before I
realized most of the class had
no idea what a knapsack was.
It's what we old people
used to call a backpack,
and they used to look more
like that than they look today.
So the knapsack
problem involves--
usually it's told in terms of a
burglar who breaks into a house
and wants to steal
a bunch of stuff
but has a knapsack
that will only
hold a finite amount of stuff
that he or she wishes to steal.
And so the burglar has to
solve the optimization problem
of stealing the stuff with
the most value while obeying
the constraint that it all
has to fit in the knapsack.
So we have an
objective function.
I'll get the most for
this when I fence it.
And a constraint, it has
to fit in my backpack.
And you can guess
which of these might be
the most valuable items here.
So here is in words, written
words what I just said orally.
There's more stuff
than you can carry,
and you have to choose
which stuff to take
and which to leave behind.
I should point out that
there are two variants of it.
There's the 0/1 knapsack
problem and the continuous.
The 0/1 would be illustrated
by something like this.
So the 0/1 knapsack problem
means you either take
the object or you don't.
I take that whole gold
bar or I take none of it.
The continuous or so-called
fractional knapsack problem
says I can take pieces of it.
So maybe if I take
in my gold bar
and shaved it into gold
dust, I then can say,
well, the whole
thing won't fit in,
but I can fit in a
path, part of it.
The continuous knapsack
problem is really boring.
It's easy to solve.
How do you think you would
solve the continuous problem?
Suppose you had over here a pile
of gold and a pile of silver
and a pile of raisins, and you
wanted to maximize your value.
Well, you'd fill up
your knapsack with gold
until you either ran out of
gold or ran out of space.
If you haven't run
out of space, you'll
now put silver in until
you run out of space.
If you still haven't
run out of space,
well, then you'll take as many
raisins as you can fit in.
But you can solve it with what's
called a greedy algorithm,
and we'll talk much more
about this as we go forward.
Where you take the best
thing first as long as
you can and then you move
on to the next thing.
As we'll see, the
0/1 knapsack problem
is much more complicated because
once you make a decision,
it will affect the
future decisions.
Let's look at an example, and
I should probably warn you,
if you're hungry, this is not
going to be a fun lecture.
So here is my least
favorite because I always
want to eat more than
I'm supposed to eat.
So the point is typically
knapsack problems
are not physical knapsacks
but some conceptual idea.
So let's say that I'm allowed
1,500 calories of food,
and these are my options.
I have to go about deciding,
looking at this food--
and it's interesting, again,
there's things showing up
on your screen that are not
showing up on my screen,
but they're harmless, things
like how my mouse works.
Anyway, so I'm trying to take
some fraction of this food,
and it can't add up to
more than 1,500 calories.
The problem might be that
once I take something that's
1,485 calories, I
can't take anything
else, or maybe 1,200 calories
and everything else is
more than 300.
So once I take one thing, it
constrains possible solutions.
A greedy algorithm,
as we'll see,
is not guaranteed to
give me the best answer.
Let's look at a
formalization of it.
So each item is represented by
a pair, the value of the item
and the weight of the item.
And let's assume the knapsack
can accommodate items
with the total weight
of no more than w.
I apologize for the
short variable names,
but they're easier
to fit on a slide.
Finally, we're going
to have a vector l
of length n representing
the set of available items.
This is assuming we have
n items to choose from.
So each element of the
vector represents an item.
So those are the items we have.
And then another
vector v is going
to indicate whether or
not an item was taken.
So essentially I'm going
to use a binary number
to represent the set of
items I choose to take.
For item three say,
if bit three is zero
I'm not taking the item.
If bit three is one, then
I am taking the item.
So it just shows I
can now very nicely
represent what I've done
by a single vector of zeros
and ones.
Let me pause for a second.
Does anyone have any
questions about this setup?
It's important to get
this setup because what
we're going to see now depends
upon that setting in your head.
So I've kind of used mathematics
to describe the backpack
problem.
And that's typically the way
we deal with these optimization
problems.
We start with some
informal description,
and then we translate them into
a mathematical representation.
So here it is.
We're going to try
and find a vector
v that maximizes the sum
of V sub i times I sub i.
Now, remember I sub i is
the value of the item.
V sub i is either zero or one
So if I didn't take the item,
I'm multiplying
its value by zero.
So it contributes
nothing to the sum.
If I did take the item, I'm
multiplying its value by one.
So the value of the item
gets added to the sum.
So that tells me the
value of V. And I
want to get the
most valuable V I
can get subject
to the constraint
that if I look at the item's
dot weight and multiply it by V,
the sum of the weights
is no greater than w.
So I'm playing the same
trick with the values
of multiplying each
one by zero or one,
and that's my constraint.
Make sense?
All right, so now we have
the problem formalized.
How do we solve it?
Well, the most obvious
solution is brute force.
I enumerate all
possible combinations
of items; that is to say,
I generate all subsets
of the items that
are available--
I don't know why it
says subjects here,
but we should have said items.
Let me fix that.
This is called the power set.
So the power set of a set
includes the empty subset.
It includes the set
that includes everything
and everything in between.
So subsets of size one,
subsets of size two, et cetera.
So now I've generated all
possible sets of items.
I can now go through
and sum up the weights
and remove all those sets that
weigh more than I'm allowed.
And then from the
remaining combinations,
choose any one whose
value is the largest.
I say choose any
one because there
could be ties, in which case
I don't care which I choose.
So it's pretty obvious
that this is going
to give you a correct answer.
You're considering
all possibilities
and choosing a winner.
Unfortunately, it's
usually not very practical.
What we see here is
that's what the power
set is if you have 100 vec.
Not very practical, right,
even for a fast computer
generating that many
possibilities is going
to take a rather long time.
So kind of disappointing.
We look at it and say, well,
we got a brute force algorithm.
It will solve the problem,
but it'll take too long.
We can't actually do it.
100 is a pretty
small number, right.
We often end up solving
optimization problems
where n is something
closer to 1,000, sometimes
even a million.
Clearly, brute force
isn't going to work.
So that raises
the next question,
are we just being stupid?
Is there a better algorithm
that I should have showed you?
I shouldn't say we.
Am I just being stupid?
Is there a better algorithm that
would have given us the answer?
The sad answer to that is
no for the knapsack problem.
And indeed many
optimization problems
are inherently exponential.
What that means is there
is no algorithm that
provides an exact solution
to this problem whose worst
case running time is not
exponential in the number
of items.
It is an exponentially
hard problem.
There is no really
good solution.
But that should not make you
sad because while there's
no perfect solution, we're going
to look at a couple of really
very good solutions that
will make this poor woman
a happier person.
So let's start with
the greedy algorithm.
I already talked to you
about greedy algorithms.
So it could hardly be simpler.
We say while the
knapsack is not full,
put the best available
item into the knapsack.
When it's full, we're done.
You do need to ask a question.
What does best mean?
Is the best item
the most valuable?
Is it the least
expensive in terms
of, say, the fewest
calories, in my case?
Or is it the highest
ratio of value to units?
Now, maybe I think a
calorie in a glass of beer
is worth more than a calorie
in a bar of chocolate,
maybe vice versa.
Which gets me to a
concrete example.
So you're about to
sit down to a meal.
You know how much you value
the various different foods.
For example, maybe
you like donuts
more than you like apples.
You have a calorie
budget, and here we're
going to have a fairly
austere budget--
it's only one meal;
it's not the whole day--
of 750 calories, and we're going
to have to go through menus
and choose what to eat.
That is as we've seen
a knapsack problem.
They should probably
have a knapsack solver
at every McDonald's
and Burger King.
So here's a menu I just made up
of wine, beer, pizza, burger,
fries, Coke,
apples, and a donut,
and the value I might
place on each of these
and the number of calories that
actually are in each of these.
And we're going to
build a program that
will find an optimal menu.
And if you don't like this
menu, you can run the program
and change the values
to be whatever you like.
Well, as you saw
if you took 60001,
we like to start with
an abstract data type,
like to organize our program
around data abstractions.
So I've got this class food.
I can initialize things.
I have a getValue,
a getCost, density,
which is going to be the value
divided by the cost, and then
a string representation.
So nothing here that you should
not all be very familiar with.
Then I'm going to have a
function called buildMenu,
which will take
in a list of names
and a list of values of equal
length and a list of calories.
They're all the same length.
And it will build the menu.
So it's going to be
a menu of tuples--
a menu of foods, rather.
And I build each food by
giving it its name, its value,
and its caloric content.
Now I have a menu.
Now comes the fun part.
Here is an implementation
of a greedy algorithm.
I called it a flexible
greedy primarily because
of this key function over here.
So you'll notice in red there's
a parameter called keyfunction.
That's going to be-- map the
elements of items to numbers.
So it will be used
to sort the items.
So I want to sort them
from best to worst,
and this function will be used
to tell me what I mean by best.
So maybe keyfunction will
just return the value or maybe
it will return the weight
or maybe it will return
some function of the density.
But the idea here
is I want to use
one greedy algorithm
independently
of my definition of best.
So I use keyfunction to
define what I mean by best.
So I'm going to come in.
I'm going to sort it
from best to worst.
And then for i in range
len of items sub copy--
I'm being good.
I've copied it.
That's why you sorted
rather than sort.
I don't want to have a side
effect in the parameter.
In general, it's not
good hygiene to do that.
And so for-- I'll go through
it in order from best to worst.
And if the value is less
than the maximum cost,
if putting it in would keep
me under the cost or not
over the cost, I put
it in, and I just
do that until I can't
put anything else in.
So I might skip a few because
I might get to the point
where there's only
a few calories left,
and the next best item is
over that budget but maybe
further down I'll find one that
is not over it and put it in.
That's why I can't exit
as soon as I reach--
as soon as I find an
item that won't fit.
And then I'll just return.
Does this make sense?
Does anyone have any doubts
about whether this algorithm
actually works?
I hope not because I
think it does work.
Let's ask the next question.
How efficient do we think it is?
What is the efficiency
of this algorithm?
Let's see where the time goes.
That's the algorithm
we just looked at.
So I deleted the
comment, so we'd
have a little more
room in the slide.
Who wants to make a guess?
By the way, this
is the question.
So please go answer
the questions.
We'll see how people do.
But we can think about
it as well together.
Well, let's see
where the time goes.
The first thing is at the sort.
So I'm going to
sort all the items.
And we heard from
Professor Grimson
how long the sort takes.
See who remembers.
Python uses something
called timsort,
which is a variant of something
called quicksort, which
has the same worst-case
complexity as merge sort.
And so we know that is n
log n where n in this case
would be the len of items.
So we know we have that.
Then we have a loop.
How many times do we
go through this loop?
Well, we go through the loop
n times, once for each item
because we do end up
looking at every item.
And if we know that,
what's the order?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN GUTTAG: N log n plus n--
I guess is order n log n, right?
So it's pretty efficient.
And we can do this for big
numbers like a million.
Log of a million times a million
is not a very big number.
So it's very efficient.
Here's some code
that uses greedy.
Takes in the items, the
constraint, in this case
will be the weight,
and just calls greedy,
but with the keyfunction
and prints what we have.
So we're going to test greedy.
I actually think I used 750 in
the code, but we can use 800.
It doesn't matter.
And here's something
we haven't seen before.
So used greedy by
value to allocate
and calls testGreedy with food,
maxUnits and Food.getValue.
Notice it's passing
the function.
That's why it's not--
no closed parentheses after it.
Used greedy to allocate.
And then we have something
pretty interesting.
What's going on
with this lambda?
So here we're going to be using
greedy by density to allocate--
actually, sorry, this
is greedy by cost.
And you'll notice
what we're doing is--
we don't want to
pass in the cost,
right, because we really want
the opposite of the cost.
We want to reverse the sort
because we want the cheaper
items to get chosen first.
The ones that have fewer
calories, not the ones that
have more calories.
As it happens,
when I define cost,
I defined it in the obvious way,
the total number of calories.
So I could have gone and written
another function to do it,
but since it was so simple,
I decided to do it in line.
So let's talk about lambda
and then come back to it.
Lambda is used to create
an anonymous function,
anonymous in the sense
that it has no name.
So you start with
the keyword lambda.
You then give it a
sequence of identifiers
and then some expression.
What lambda does is
it builds a function
that evaluates that expression
on those parameters and returns
the result of evaluating
the expression.
So instead of writing def, I
have inline defined a function.
So if we go back to it here,
you can see that what I've done
is lambda x one divided
by Food.getCost of x.
Notice food is the
class name here.
So I'm taking the function
getCost from the class food,
and I'm passing it the parameter
x, which is going to be what?
What's the type
of x going to be?
I can wait you out.
What is the type of x have to
be for this lambda expression
to make sense?
Well, go back to the class food.
What's the type of the
argument of getCost?
What's the name of the
argument to getCost?
That's an easier question.
We'll go back and
we'll look at it.
What's the type of the
argument to getCost?
AUDIENCE: Food.
JOHN GUTTAG: Food.
Thank you.
So I do have--
speaking of food, we
do have a tradition
in this class
that people who answer
questions correctly get
rewarded with food.
Oh, Napoli would
have caught that.
So it has to be of
type food because it's
self in the class food.
So if we go back to here, this
x has to be of type food, right.
And sure enough, when
we use it, it will be.
Let's now use it.
I should point out that lambda
can be really handy as it
is here, and it's
possible to write
amazing, beautiful,
complicated lambda expressions.
And back in the good old days of
6001 people learned to do that.
And then they learned
that they shouldn't.
My view on lambda expressions
is if I can't fit it
in a single line,
I just go right
def and write a
function definition
because it's easier to debug.
But for one-liners,
lambda is great.
Let's look at using greedy.
So here's this
function testGreedy,
takes foods and the
maximum number of units.
And it's going to
go through and it's
going to test all three
greedy algorithms.
And we just saw that, and
then here is the call of it.
And so I picked up some
names and the values.
This is just the menu we saw.
I'm going to build the
menus, and then I'm
going to call testGreedys.
So let's go look at the
code that does this.
So here you have it or maybe
you don't, because every time
I switch applications
Windows decides I don't want
to show you the screen anyway.
This really shouldn't
be necessary.
Keep changes.
Why it keeps forgetting,
I don't know.
Anyway, so here's the code.
It's all the code
we just looked at.
Now let's run it.
Well, what we see
here is that we
use greedy by value to
allocate 750 calories,
and it chooses a
burger, the pizza,
and the wine for a total of--
a value of 284 happiness
points, if you will.
On the other hand, if
we use greedy by cost,
I get 318 happiness points and
a different menu, the apple,
the wine, the cola, the
beer, and the donut.
I've lost the pizza
and the burger.
I guess this is what
I signed up for when
I put my preferences on.
And here's another solution
with 318, apple, wine--
yeah, all right.
So I actually got
the same solution,
but it just found them
in a different order.
Why did it find them
in a different order?
Because the sort order was
different because in this case
I was sorting by density.
From this, we see
an important point
about greedy algorithms, right,
that we used the algorithm
and we got different answers.
Why do we have
different answers?
The problem is that
a greedy algorithm
makes a sequence of
local optimizations,
chooses the locally optimal
answer at every point,
and that doesn't
necessarily add up
to a globally optimal answer.
This is often illustrated by
showing an example of, say,
hill climbing.
So imagine you're in a terrain
that looks something like this,
and you want to get to the
highest point you can get.
So you might choose
as a greedy algorithm
if you can go up, go up; if
you can't go up, you stop.
So whenever you get
a choice, you go up.
And so if I start here, I
could right in the middle
maybe say, all right, it's not
up but it's not down either.
So I'll go either left or right.
And let's say I go
right, so I come to here.
Then I'll just make my way
up to the top of the hill,
making a locally optimal
decision head up at each point,
and I'll get here and I'll
say, well, now any place I go
takes me to a lower point.
So I don't want to do it, right,
because the greedy algorithm
says never go backwards.
So I'm here and I'm happy.
On the other hand, if I had
gone here for my first step,
then my next step up would take
me up, up, up, I'd get to here,
and I'd stop and say, OK,
no way to go but down.
I don't want to go down.
I'm done.
And what I would find is I'm
at a local maximum rather than
a global maximum.
And that's the problem
with greedy algorithms,
that you can get stuck
at a local optimal point
and not get to the best one.
Now, we could ask
the question, can
I just say don't
worry about a density
will always get me
the best answer?
Well, I've tried a
different experiment.
Let's say I'm feeling
expansive and I'm going
to allow myself 1,000 calories.
Well, here what we see is the
winner will be greedy by value,
happens to find a better
answer, 424 instead of 413.
So there is no way
to know in advance.
Sometimes this definition
of best might work.
Sometimes that might work.
Sometimes no definition
of best will work,
and you can't get
to a good solution--
you get to a good solution.
You can't get to
an optimal solution
with a greedy algorithm.
On Wednesday, we'll talk
about how do you actually
guarantee finding an
optimal solution in a better
way than brute force.
See you then.